hi guys i'm jessica lugo and this is
celebrity recipe royale
today i'm going to be testing out four
celebrity banana bread recipes to find
out which one
is the best on today's lineup we have
betty white
lucy hale bibi rexa and chrissy teigen
so which celebrity has the best banana
bread recipe
let's find out who's bringing in the
bread so first up
everyone's favorite grandma betty white
betty white starts off with peeling and
smashing her bananas
then she puts wheat flour in a bowl salt
baking powder
baking soda sugar and mixes it all
together
then she creates a hollow center adds in
her bananas
milk walnuts and an egg
and mixes it all up together super easy
then she sprays down her pan with
vegetable oil and pours in the mixture
then she bakes it for 50 minutes
until golden brown and voila betty
white's banana bread
just by looking at this i can tell it's
definitely made with a
white sugar this cake looks a little bit
dry
the nuts are nicely throughout the whole
thing though i know that can be
difficult with banana bread sometimes
things like sink a lot
[Music]
it's crunchy i really like crunchy i
think it's really flavorful
i can definitely taste like that banana
flavor inside of it
it's got a very good like basic classic
banana bread flavor
i would expect to try this i would say
at a very good bake sale if i could give
it any criticism i'd say i'd like it to
be just a little bit more moist
i'm sure if you took the recipe and
added you know one more banana that
would probably like amp that up a little
bit
but other than that it's really good
and next up is lucy hale she starts off
by whisking three eggs together
peels her bananas breaks them up into
pieces and throws it right into the
mixture
then she smashes the egg mixture and the
bananas all together
she then adds coconut oil almond flour
baking soda and a whole lot of sugar
mixes it all up
adds in vanilla extract greases up her
bread pan
and then fills up the bread pan a
quarter of the way with the bread
mixture
she then dollops in almond butter and
spreads it around as best as she can
don't judge here guys and if that wasn't
enough she throws in some dark chocolate
chips
and then tops it off with the remaining
mixture
she bakes it for an hour or until the
toothpick comes out
clean and no judgments here guys here
you have it
lucy hales banana bread okay this one
looks really
dense it looks like there's like some
kind of chocolate or
fruit in it it's very moist but
crispy on the edges
[Music]
oh that's really good i like the
chocolate in there if i knew somebody
was like a chocolate lover
and also like banana bread i think this
is the perfect combination of the two
hmm this is really good actually i don't
even know what this is but it's so good
this is a totally different take than
the other banana bread but it's really
soft you can tell it's you know like
very fresh it's
very very moist i would definitely get
this at a restaurant
probably for dessert if i could change
anything about it
i'd say i just want to be a little bit
crispier on the outside
it's really chocolatey it's really like
fudgy it's almost like a banana
chocolate like brownie texture
this one's really good i just keep want
to keep eating it
next into the ring bb rexa bb starts off
with mixing flour baking soda and salt
together
then in a separate bowl she whisks
together two eggs in a blender
yes i set it a blender she adds in her
butter and brown sugar
and then she blends it together she then
adds in the egg mixture
and blends it together this blender
clearly needs some help so don't forget
to mix it together with a fork
need be she then takes her bananas and
smashes them together
she then adds in the smashed bananas
flour
and walnuts and blends it all together
like i said don't forget to wipe down
the sides
once the mixture is done she sprays down
her bread pan
and pours the mixture right in
[Music]
she then smooths out the top layer
evenly right before she throws it into
the oven
and she bakes it for 55 minutes and
there you have it
bb rexa's homemade banana bread so this
one is definitely a more like
classic banana bread i'm having like
banana bread deja vu this like looks
exactly like a banana bread i've had
before
i think it actually is a tiny bit on the
dry side but
i love the crunchiness on the edges if
the first banana bread and the second
banana bread had a child
this banana bread would be what it had
that one doesn't have like the chocolate
flavor but it's really like
moist it's really dense but light at the
same time
i would definitely order this at a cafe
i'm going to need the recipe anywhere
that sells this would definitely be my
go-to spot
it's got a good crunch to it to the top
of the crust so you get a couple of
different textures you're getting the
soft interior
but then like the kind of crusty outside
and last but not least
america's milk chrissy teigen chrissy
starts off by peeling and smashing her
bananas
she measures them out to two cups puts
them in a bowl and adds in the eggs
she adds in canola oil and mixes it all
together
then she takes flour baking soda salt
and her lethal weapon vanilla instant
pudding
she mixes together the banana mixture
and the dry ingredients
oh yes this is what i'm talking about
and if that wasn't good enough
she adds in pieces of dark chocolate and
shredded coconut
and then mixes it all together she then
butters and flours her bundt
pan make sure you get it all good
because it won't come out if you don't
lastly she adds in the mixture she then
puts it into the oven to bake for about
60 to 80 minutes
and just like that chrissy teigen's
banana bread
oh this one looks good really great
plating because there's like coconut
flakes on top
smells on the sweeter side but you still
get
banana it's not an overpowering sweet
it definitely tastes healthier than the
other banana breads
the coconut is really good with it this
is really good
wow i don't know if i'm necessarily a
big fan of the coconut i think it adds a
strange texture i make banana bread a
lot at home and i've never tried coconut
don't see any like banana chunk areas
which is good but
i wish there was a little bit more
banana in it i like that there's a
really good like lightness in it
and then there's chocolate to kind of
like cut that and make it a little bit
more dense
it's got a really good kind of cakey
crumb structure to it
overall this one was really solid really
good
so which celebrity has the best banana
bread recipe
let's find out my favorite is going to
have to be
number two it was so moist on the inside
and crunchy around the edges
and i think there was some sort of
chocolate in it which i really loved
about it
really i love lucy hale that was really
good
i'm gonna have to go with four that is
some really great creativity
plating was all there i would expect to
find that anywhere
the chocolate and the coconut added a
really great touch
oh my god okay well i'm definitely gonna
need the recipe
i'd probably say my favorite was number
two i am personally a big chocolate
lover
and i prefer a moister product oh
interesting lucy hell is our banana
bread
champ so that was the season finale but
don't let that stop you
leave a comment and let us know what
celebrities or recipes
you'd like to see next
[Music]
you